so Margo can you explain the story of
the movie well uh
Bobby land is perfect and the Bobbies
are having a perfect day after perfect
day and everything's just wonderful in
Barbie land unless you're a Ken
or until you have an existential crisis
which my Bobby does what about the rest
of you like who who's your Barbie
America I'm not a Barbie I mean I am a
Barbie because we're all Barbie's unless
you're a Ken then you're not a Barbie
but um I'm a human in the movie I'm I
think there's Barbie there's Barbie life
Barbie land and then and in the last
trailer you kind of see the hint of like
Barbie and Ken are headed toward the
real world and in the real world my
character Gloria
uh encounters Barbie and
um it's a it's a connection and and
hijinks ensue from there and I think
that's all I'm allowed to say okay and
then I don't want to spoil everything
who's your Barbie who do you play did
you guys ever have a Barbie like the one
Barbie that you designate as like
her were you like cut their hair
on them that's the one I play
you're like what if I colored her hair
she needs a haircut
I love her mommy can you do the splits
in real life or do they have to like can
go to about there and then the whole
system breaks down I can't I can't do it
oh my God way to go then the editing job
oh yeah no they did they did this whole
like technical thing where like my legs
are always
um at a 180.
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
[Music]